قالت العديد من جماعات حقوق الإنسان
مرارا وتكرارا إن تصرفات إسرائيل
يمكن أن ترقى إلى جرائم حرب أو أعمال
عقاب جماعي وهي بالطبع
غير قانونية بموجب القانون الدولي ولكن
من خلال تقديم الأسلحة والمساعدات والدعم السياسي
لإسرائيل أه الولايات المتحدة
متواطئة حسنا مارك إسرائيل لا
ترتكب  أي جرائم حرب على الإطلاق وكما
تعلم أه بموجب القانون الدولي يحق لإسرائيل
الدفاع عن نفسها أعتقد أن
الجميع متفقون أعتقد أن الجميع
متفقون على أن لإسرائيل الحق في
القضاء على حماس لقد زرعت حماس
نفسها داخل السكان المدنيين وهذا أمر
ساخر وفظيع
أنا متأكد من أنك تدرك ذلك لكي أكون واضحًا،
فأنت تقاطع لا لا لا، أنت تسيء
تمثيل بياني، لم أقل
أن إسرائيل ليس لها
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها، السؤال هو هل
تلتزم إسرائيل  جرائم الحرب
حق الدفاع عن النفس ليس
غير محدود بموجب القانون الدولي وبالتالي
السؤال أه خارج مجرد
القول لدينا الحق في الدفاع عن
أنفسنا هل هي جريمة حرب قلت
المجتمع الدولي يوافق
المجتمع الدولي في الواقع لا
يوافق  لا، المجتمع الدولي
يوافق على أن لإسرائيل الحق في
مهاجمة حماس، حسنًا، لا أعتقد أن
أحدًا يختلف مع ذلك، لا
أعتقد أن هناك دولة واحدة في العالم، هذا ما
أقوله، هذا مجرد رجل من القش لا أحد
يجادل فيه  أنهم ليس لديهم الحق
في الرد على السؤال هو هل لديهم الحق في أن
أحاول ما أقوله هو أنا ولهذا
السبب أريد تجنب رجل القش
ولا أريد أن أضيع وقتك في
مناقشة ما إذا كان  أو ليس لإسرائيل
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها نحن متفقون على أن
لها الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
حماس أو الرد على هذا الهجوم هذا
ليس ما محل خلاف
السؤال هو هل الهجمات
متناسبة هل الهجمات أه
تمييز بما فيه الكفاية أي لا
تهاجم  المدنيون عندما يكون من الممكن تجنب ذلك،
ألا يهاجمون أهدافًا
تعتبر غير قابلة للاستهداف بموجب القانون الدولي،
نعم، انظر، مارك تعلم أنني لا
أهتم حقًا بما تقوله الأمم المتحدة، أعني أن الأمم المتحدة
لم تكن عادلة بشأن هذه القضية على مدار
الخمسين عامًا الماضية هنا  هذا هو
الواقع بموجب القانون الدولي،
يحق لإسرائيل مهاجمة حماس بموجب
القانون الدولي عندما تهاجم
عدوًا عندما تستهدف عدوًا إلى
حد وجود
أضرار جانبية ضد المدنيين، وهذا ليس
ضد مارك، أنت تقاطعني لا
أنا.  أطرح سؤالًا توضيحيًا
ما هو القانون ما هو القانون الذي قلته ما هو القانون الذي
قلته بموجب
القوانين الدولية للحرب ما بين ما بين ما
الدولي الذي أسأله لأنني
أناشد خبرتك ما هي
القواعد الدولية للحرب التي تنص على أنك
يمكنهم مهاجمة حماس بالطريقة التي كانت
لديهم بها الدولة الإسرائيلية التي
يقول كل قانون حرب أنني بحاجة إليك أريدك
أن تذكر اسمًا واحدًا يا سيدي، هذه
ليست إجابة صادقة أيًا كان مجرد
القول بأن القانون الدولي لا يجعله
واحدًا  القانون الدولي ليس
كتابًا سحريًا، القانون الدولي موجود،
هناك مجموعة من القانون الدولي
تتعامل مع الأضرار الجانبية، إسرائيل
لا تستهدف مدنيًا واحدًا،
إنهم يستهدفون حماس أينما
حددوا حماس، فهم يهاجمون حماس إذا كانت
حماس مدمجة مع أطفال إسرائيل
سأبذل كل ما في وسعي لتجنب تلك
الخسائر التي كنت فيها في غرفة الحرب لقد
كنت في غرفة الحرب عندما
هاجمت إسرائيل حماس مرة أخرى في عام 2019 حسنًا، لقد
رأيت الآلام التي يبذلونها لتجنب
وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين نعم هناك
ضحايا من  حرب في كل حرب
كانت هناك خسائر تجري الآن
في أوكرانيا وروسيا، ولا أسمع
أحدًا يصرخ ويصرخ بشأن
الضحايا المدنيين، هناك الكثير من
الأطفال في أوكرانيا في روسيا يقولون إن
الشيوعي الدولي لم يقل شيئًا
عن مرتزقة الحرب في روسيا، على الإطلاق
غير واقعي ولكنك قلت شيئًا آخر
أعتقد أنه مثير للاهتمام أيضًا، فقد
قلت إن هناك أضرارًا جانبية في
كل الحروب التي تستهدف مخيمًا للاجئين في مخيم جبل للاجئين
ليس مثالًا على
استهداف حماس، وهناك فقط عدد قليل من
الضحايا الذين استهدفوا مخيمًا للاجئين
حيث يوجد أطفال  إن استهداف
المستشفيات والمساجد والكنائس
كلها انتهاكات مباشرة للقانون الدولي
على الرغم من أنك
تقول باستمرار إنه لم يخبرني أي
مستشفى استهدفته إسرائيل
أخبرني أي مستشفى قلت إن إسرائيل تستهدف
المستشفيات، المستشفى الوحيد الذي تم
استهدافه حتى الآن  في هذه الحرب تم استهدافها
من قبل الجهاد الإسلامي لقد ثبت بشكل
مؤكد لقد ثبت بشكل
مؤكد أن المقر الرئيسي لحماس
يقع تحت مستشفى ألفا في مدينة غزة
الآن أنت تعرف ما حدث قبل بضعة
أيام
دعني هل ستدعني
أنتهي  لا أستطيع أن أسمح لك، لا أستطيع أن أسمح لك
بذكر 15 شيئًا
غير واقعي ولا يمكن الطعن فيها،
يسعدني أن أسمح لك بالتحدث ولكني
سأطرح سؤالًا توضيحيًا ما هو
المستقل أه المرجع ما المصدر
ما التحقيق  لقد أثبت ذلك من
أثبت أنه مستشفى ألفا
لأنه حقيقة مثبتة من أثبت
ذلك، قدمت إسرائيل أدلة اسأل اسأل
وكالة المخابرات المركزية اسأل اسأل أي شخص يدرس وكالة المخابرات المركزية يا
سيدي، أنت لا تثق في
الحكومة، أنت لا تثق  لا تثق في
الحكومة الأمريكية، لا تثق في
الحكومة الإسرائيلية، من ينبغي أن نثق في حماس،
تريد أن تثق في حماس، ثق في كاماس، حسنًا،
هل توافق على استهداف
مخيم للاجئين به أطفال وبالغون
ليسوا أعضاء في حماس وليسوا أعضاءً في حماس؟
من شأنه أن
يشكل استهدافًا لمدنيين من قبل الجهات الفاعلة في الجيش. أنا
لا أوافق تمامًا على ذلك ولا
أوافق تمامًا على ما إذا كانت إسرائيل كذلك إذا كانت إسرائيل
تستهدف حماس في مخيم للاجئين
وهي تحدد هجماتها على
حماس وهناك أضرار جانبية
هناك أضرار جانبية  الحرب
التي تسمى الحرب، هذا ما هي عليه
إسرائيل تجادل بأن حماس موجودة في كل مكان
في غزة وأنهم تحت كل
مستشفى موجودون في كل
جامعة وأنت توافق على هذا الحق،
يمكننا أن نتفق على أنه لا إسرائيل لا
تعتقد أنهم كذلك  في كل مكان تعتقد إسرائيل
أنهم موجودون في مكانهم مرة أخرى عندما
تقصف مخيمًا للاجئين، ليس هناك
سبب للاعتقاد بأن هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة
للوصول إلى هدف حماس عندما
يتم قصف مستشفى، ليس هناك سبب للاعتقاد بأن هذه
هي الطريقة الوحيدة للقيام بذلك، لذا  لماذا
يعتقد المجتمع الدولي بأكمله أن هذه جرائم حرب
وليس أنت لأنني أعتقد أن لدي
وجهة نظر غير متحيزة وأعتقد أن هناك الكثير
من معاداة السامية في العالم، كل ما
قلته للتو، كل نقطة دحضتها للتو، لم
أقل ذلك أبدًا  مرة أخرى، ما
أقوله هو أن ما أقوله هو أن ما
أقوله وليس ما
وضعته للتو في فمي والذي
لم يكن صحيحًا هو أنه ليس خيارًا ثنائيًا،
إنه ليس خيارًا ثنائيًا، نحن نفعل ذلك.  علينا أن
نختار بين ترك حماس تفعل
ما تريد وبين قصف
الأطفال الأبرياء يمكننا أن نكون إستراتيجيين يمكننا أن
نكون مدروسين ويمكننا اتباع
القانون الدولي الذي يقول أنه
لا يمكنك تفجير MOS ولا يمكنك
التفجير أه  اه اه مواقع ثقافية لا يمكنك
تفجير الكنائس صحيح هذا هو
القانون الدولي الإرهابيون
يختبئون في المساجد في المستشفيات في
المدارس كان هناك قاذفات صواريخ
في المساجد قاذفات صواريخ في المدارس
يعني تعرف أنك أنت أنت
أنت  نحن نركز على مجموعة افتراضية
من مبادئ القانون الدولي التي
تقول: لا تقصفوا المستشفيات، لا تقصفوا
المدارس، لا تقصفوا المساجد، أوافق على أنه لا
ينبغي لنا أن نقصف أعضاء الكنيست، لا ينبغي لنا أن نقصف
المدارس، لا ينبغي لنا أن نقصف الكنائس
ما لم يكن هناك إرهابيون
يحاولون قتلك، فإن إسرائيل
تفعل كل ما في وسعها لنقل المدنيين
بعيدًا عن طريق الأذى، أعني أنهم يبذلون
قصارى جهدهم.